officer Tai is one of many police
officers across the country who have
recently died in the line of duty so
dozens gathered in Henderson tonight to
talk about Community safety Sasha Loftus
joins us live from Metro headquarters
with more
Denise and Brian as Metro Police and the
community mourn for officer time many
are now turning their attention to the
number of deadly police shootings we've
seen recently this comes as officer and
civilian safety were discussed at an
event tonight in Henderson
I'm sorry to report that one of our
officers was killed in the line of duty
this morning Metro
Metro
Police say officer Trung Tai who had
been with the department for over 20
years lost his life while responding to
a domestic disturbance call near UNLV
Thursday morning within the last 48 hour
hours eight officers have been shot in
the line of duty across four states this
just the lay latest in a string of
deadly police shootings here locally and
across the country but in the last two
weeks we've had two officer involved
shootings right here it's something Jeff
Crampton of the Henderson Police
Officers Association wants to address
during a community event Representatives
spoke on ways people can keep themselves
and officers safe call us we will come
while Crampton touched on a valley-wide
rise in crime and a chronic Staffing
issue our response times are taking
longer because there's fewer cops out
there patrolling it's a conversation
many hope will lead to a safer change
all across Southern Nevada it's
affecting the community the children
senior citizens everyone is being
affected by it
now officers also talked about the
importance of speaking up if you see
something wrong or awry they discussed
how Community involvement is really key
to preventing any kind of crime here in
the valley reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now